all right the Bears will be back on the
field at some point and via draftkings
the all-important who will be the
starting quarterback prop week 1 Nick
falls - 167 that is oddly specific but
you bet 167 to win 100 Mitchel tree
Biscay + 130 this one to me is a
no-brainer it's gonna be false right
unless Falls gets injured in training
camp for the preseason which I guess we
can't rule out given that he got injured
in week 1 last year it's gonna be false
he's winning that job I yeah I would
hope so but I don't know if you're gonna
just throw that out there big Fool's has
one of the most interesting careers of
any quarterback in terms of the highs
and the lows and I don't know what foals
you get in camp I don't know how long
the camps gonna be like I I would bet
foals but I'm not gonna sit here and
tell you it's a guarantee it's kind of
crazy to say it's a guarantee knowing
that Nick Foles hasn't been the most
consistent guy in his career well and I
think that's a little bit overblown
right he had that huge doughnut hole
between his two stints in Philadelphia
and we just assumed he stunk the entire
time he was away when he played in
Kansas City in 2016 with Matt naggy as
the offensive coordinator the Chiefs his
numbers were not horrible he had a
limited stint when Alex Smith had a
concussion and there was a sense hey
Alex Smith can have the same thing
happened to him now that happened to him
in San Francisco because here's Andy
Reid's guy nick foles the guy drafted by
Reid in 2012 when Negi was there not as
offensive coordinator but as just an
assistant coach as he was starting his
career couple of stints between naggy
and Falls and Falls wasn't bad the only
disaster and I know you're not gonna
want to hear this
the only disaster for Nick Foles was
with your guy Jeff Fisher in st. Louis
that was the year that was so bad that
we have we have this sense that Nick
Falls is you know an up and down with
wild swings and he really isn't that
good just because that one year with the
Rams
was so horribly bad well I think it's
also the up and downs I mean Jaguars
last year obviously he got hurt but then
he wasn't able to get his job back and
if you have the ceiling of Super Bowl
MVP that immediately makes you a
volatile court
back if your answer to playoffs to the
starter every year and you're a
journeyman
right yeah I won't disagree with that
the fact that he had done incredible run
of success and was a Super Bowl MVP I
guess that does set a pretty high bar
for where does your career is so I'll
give you that right how many Super Bowl
MVPs are on there what 16 how many teams
is he playing seven so I Nick Foles of
what will be the starter there we go
that's the answer you want that's the
answer you want but but I think Nick
Foles has the potential to be good and
he's a great teammate and here's the
other thing too the benefits the Bears
if true Biscay wins the job Falls will
be the ultimate teammate he will be the
best backup he can be he will support
Mitchell true Biscay and if true Biscay
gets hurt at some point Falls will come
right and he won't miss a beat and and
you're actually better off you really
are better off if true Biscay wins the
starting job if he ends it on merit if
this wakes him up and he plays like he
did two years ago we forget that he
played fairly well two years ago we
think about last year but if he ends up
being good this year good enough to win
the starting job that is the best-case
scenario because then you have the great
insurance policy in Nick Foles mm-hmm
absolutely and Nick Foles throws a very
catchable ball that's my favorite part
about Nick Foles the Dolphins starting
dolphins starting quarterback week one
Ryan Fitzpatrick - 400 - etana bi-lo a +
350 Josh Rosen + 2000 they should just
go ahead make that + 20,000 for Josh
Rosen who's it going to be between fits
and - uh I would take a shot at - here I
know that there's they probably want to
sit him for a little bit because of
injury because of offseason you know not
having the full offseason but you don't
think - uh if they get even a shortened
camp that he wouldn't win that job
because he's that good of a quarterback
I for those prices I would take a shot
on - uh
well I remember saying last year when
they traded for Josh Rosen that the
ultimate litmus test as to whether or
not Rosen is their guy is whether or not
he can beat out Ryan Fitzpatrick and
training camp so that same analysis
applies here if - is your guy he should
be able to beat out Ryan Fitzpatrick in
training camp and if he can't you have a
problem
with what you did with your fifth
overall pick in the draft so health
would be the only thing that would keep
it from me and I think it's kind of
funny because before the draft all we
heard from Nick Saban was how great TOA
is and if you pass on tour you're making
a huge mistake
now Nick's saying to has got to learn
how to protect himself so he doesn't get
any yeah that was the concern Nick there
wasn't a concern about his ability to
play it's about his ability to play as a
bloody on the field so anyway I saw I'd
lean Toa but I just worried that that
yeah can he stay healthy through
training camp and preseason and be ready
to go week one all right we need to take
a break I think we have what let's do
one more Chargers starting quarterback
week one
Tyrod Taylor - 335 Justin Herbert plus
300 and a couple of other names one guy
not on the roster Cam Newton plus 2500
that ain't happening it's coming down to
tie rod and Herbert who do you think and
I tie rod - 335 my guess is they've said
enough that that he is the guy just like
he was in Cleveland he may not have the
job for very long but he'll at least be
the guy out of the gates yeah I think
he'll be the guy out of the gates but
I'm wondering what the plan is inside
the walls the Chartres facility of
Justin Herbert what is it look like
because when you take a quarterback that
early in the draft and to not start them
it always gives you a little bit of a
pause you're like okay you're not
starting him and you're also not
starting them for some proven like
future Hall of Fame quarterback here
it's Tyrod Taylor no offense to him but
if you're taken with a six pick why
isn't he starting I made the same
argument when the Bears took mr. Biscay
and Mike Glennon was starting and it's
like you got to just throw your guy out
there at some point if you're going to
to use that type of draft capital on
them so I would say tie rod but if it
goes longer than a month or two then
it's a head scratcher you know the last
time they used a top 10 pick on a
quarterback Philip Rivers sat for two
years behind Drew Brees and it's amazing
to think at one point they had both Drew
Brees and Philip Rivers on the same
roster for multiple seasons all right
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports